everyone this is chris uh i'm chris
i can't see myself
because it's covering it so i got a
point
we both need this way
this is chris cosmic culture he's also
like a room away from me we live in the
same place
um be sure to subscribe to him if you
haven't yet we're going to do a live
break down here we're just going to see
this see see how it works we're going to
see how it works
so let's go ahead and start at the
beginning
but in the beginning it opens up the
same as
it does in the very first ironman movie
this is the start of the mcu here we'll
take it back a little bit there's even
the part where they talk about and they
do the peace sign as we can see right
here and the events play out the same
the events play out the same until we
get and to this moment right here
missile comes down he sees stark
industry
and instead of
from here on out this is the point where
it changes from what happens to iron man
to what happens in this new universe
right because then killmonger comes
grabs it
and checks it
and it even says killmonger on his vest
and why is that because he's he's a navy
seal right now right
so this kind of shows us
not shows us but tells us a little bit
of the past that killmonger had before
and i mean
i think most of us have seen the episode
you're probably watching this if you've
seen the episode
we know that his intentions aren't so
good but basically from here killmonger
saves them and they kind of go off right
now
this is where the watchers start to show
us that all these events that would
eventually go on to happen
all the way up until this point right
here
tony stark aka iron man snapping to save
you know the entire universe they don't
happen
and this actually makes you wonder
since killmonger has killed a lot of
like the heroes
tony stark
black panther
don shadow
well rhodey
um
the earth is missing a lot
the earth is missing a lot of their
protectors and thanos is still coming
right
thanos is still out there trying to
kill half the population physically
while also trying to obtain the stone so
we can do in a snap
so
killmonger is really really altered
the events of what happens in the mcu
specifically
infinity ward end game
i mean i think it's really cool that we
get the sequence from the watcher and he
keeps referencing and we definitely need
to point this out the main mcu timeline
yeah right and i realized that in this
episode when we saw this scene that you
have pulled up there
um like he keeps referencing back to the
main mcu timeline
and i guess it really was the sacred
timeline so maybe these all of these in
the in the what f episode are branching
off from the time of loki so there are
there is that main connection there as
well which i always think is just kind
of interesting to make out i think the
most asked question to you and me
from all of you guys is
are these guys going to connect to the
main mcu timeline and i still don't know
the answer to that just yet but if
anything the main sacred timeline is
there
and um the watcher is aware of that and
i think the watcher is actually the
connection to the main timeline because
if this watcher
is the watcher over all of the
multiverse and the producers have said
that this does connect to the mcu
well
okay that means the watcher is the
watcher of
our secret type bring all that knowledge
over right right well this happened here
and if you do it this way it happened
this way so that's actually really true
so out of everything we've seen
and you know it's just kind of
background information and something
that has been on our face but not
addressed you know if the watcher makes
his way over to the mcu and he's aware
of the main mcu timeline which obviously
he is if he's referencing iron man snap
here
if we get him in the in the real live
action site he can reference any of this
anything like yeah well when it when you
did it this way this is what happened
it's like hey we watched that what if
now also you have to keep in mind for
what if in the main mcu
multiverse of madness makes anything
possible right but
at the watcher in the comics even though
he's like sworn not to be able to
interfere
he does
he still does he still does eventually
and i think that'll happen in the mc
right and at one point in time in the
comics like the council of all the
watchers they kick him out
now eventually he gets back in because
he still watches over earth when they
kick him out right
but he loves the fantastic four he helps
fantastic four
and i think perhaps in multiverse of
madness
we're gonna see the watcher maybe
interfere and maybe that's how the
rumored live-action captain carter comes
in right because i think she comes from
one of these universes that we're seeing
and what if
i think
because it's clear we've seen by now
marvel actually released it today the
the halfway point trailer or whatever
they call it
and we saw some more team-ups
and i think this is leading to a bunch
of multiverses colliding into each other
um and eventually will lead into the the
live-action mcu
and i think like you just said the
watcher is the big link there so that's
important to notice for sure oh for sure
i i think it's all the watcher all right
so getting back here subtitles since i
don't have any uh
um i can't put any audio so a villain
was given a new chance this part's kind
of interesting because i mean they they
lead you to believe that you know
killmonger can actually be good and we
do believe it for a while now this part
is kind of sad
because
we figure out kind of what we figured
out at the end of the first iron man
right we know who the real bad guy is
and
tony stark has promoted c-o-o in his
place now we're skipping all of that
obviously because we're not going
through any of the events of the first
iron man because tony stark doesn't
actually ever become iron man
so if we skip here
we know who she is
after all these years tony still has you
picking up the dry cleaning
i do anything and everything that mr
sark requires
including occasionally taking out the
trash and yep there it is
abba dye stain
move
that was awesome by the co oh yeah it's
kind of cool how this kind of gives you
i mean it
it doesn't tell us anything that we
didn't really know from the first iron
man
but again what i think i'm missing from
this episode
is it doesn't it doesn't tell us where
like the universe changed
you know what i mean like it doesn't
tell us like and this is the reason
in this universe killmonger decided to
go save tony or he stumbled upon that
information because that's the
difference
in the universe killmonger finding that
information and saving tony now
he outs of adayah
and he becomes a ceo
he gets arrested happy doesn't get
promoted not like he was supposed to his
head of security it's unfortunate
because i love happy and i honestly
thought he was going to save the day of
going blam blam blam
blam punches the guy blame him
in there
yeah but
so as we go through
party at tony's house party at the
party party at the mansion you know
getting major you know iron man iron man
2 vibes here
yep um
roadie's there you know
peppers talk to him
so this is this is kind of funny because
tony's promoting him right to the to the
co
but killmonger is going i'm just a
soldier right
i'm just a soldier and this is a perfect
like
play here right it's it's it's a very
sneaky
koi here as he's as this is exactly what
he wants right he wants to get in close
with tony he wants to get really tight
with stark industries
and he's doing that by kind of
playing it off like well you know i'm
just a soldier i'm not that smart of a
guy you know what i mean blah blah blah
blah and tony eats it up now he saved
tony's life
but tony eats it up
now this is a part where i don't think
i think the arrogance of tony stark gets
in the way a little bit too much oh for
sure because perfect way of putting it
right just the arrogance of tony stark
just to trust this guy just because he
saved his life
just because you know he's navy seal
which i mean i would like to think you
could trust in abco we're obviously
talking about fictional universe
um but i think against navy seals please
don't come find it i have friends that
are navy seals they're freaking awesome
yeah so but this part right here i mean
and he's drinking right mind you but
he's pretty much drinking the whole
entire time in this episode up until his
death you know like if we think about
that but so that's when he says i want
you by my side i want a killer
figuratively but you know a literal one
wouldn't matter it wouldn't be bad
either because you know
it's nice especially if you're tony
stark now pepper meets with um
roadie right
and roadie's like his slate's clean
right can't find anything on him and
pepper says like yeah and that's why i
don't trust him this is this is kind of
where we kind of start to go okay
what's going on does he actually want
something
or
you know is pepper just being paranoid
but as we go on
tony kind of shows them all of his toys
they bond over their fathers yeah that's
cool now killmonger eric knows
everything he knows everything about
tony stark this is his plan for a long
time like this is his vengeance right so
instead of the events of black panther
happening
it's completely different his plan to
get back into wakanda and take over
wakanda is to actually go through tony
stark he's a major part of his plan why
because he has to build what they call
their gundams right and he actually says
i like anime so it literally is
kind of designed after gundam wing which
is kind of cool for the animation
right for the animation
easter egg there
so killmonger you again you know uses
what he knows will work with tony they
both lost their fathers right
um their parents are both orphans in a
way right so he uses that and he tells
tony you know i had this idea and it was
basically to
build a gundam is what he said there was
an idea there was an idea that iron man
would become the death of himself by
trusting a random person that he met
that saved his life
that's not how it goes it's kind of good
so
they design it right and it's funny
because at one point in time they're
searching for a power supply and he says
right here hey
if we could maneuver miniaturize
our arc reactor
and he's like no that wouldn't work no
that wouldn't work that wouldn't work
i'm just drunk
which is obviously what ends up
happening in iron man and it's obviously
his arc reactor which he would never go
on to get in this universe because he
would never go and become iron man he
would never have the shrap metal
constantly trying to kill his heart
which is what he did the art right after
four but so that's just like a little
pun there but then the idea comes to use
vibranium and eric still has some left
and
that's what they decide they need they
need some vibranium so who
now comes into the picture claw
claw because he has the vibranium and
where did we learn this from
age of ultron which and we were in the
same building
what do you mean
that building the little locker where
they had all the vibranium yeah same
build yeah it's the same for major
voltron yep yeah same with atrial
fibrilla
um now
problem is
they need kind of a diplomatic way to do
everything and pepper kind of realizes
that
this is kind of kill monger's plan
because she's like oh you probably don't
agree and then he's like no i i do agree
and then he says but unless we can
secure some kind of diplomatic cover
now again
all part of the plant because he wants
to kill roadie
right he wants war machine out well i
guess he's not never becomes war machine
that doesn't happen right again
huge alterations in this universe uh
avengers probably either don't get
formed or form in a very very different
way because i guess yeah i guess fury's
still there and caps you know under the
ice maybe or no not at this point he's
not on the ice but
so he says we're gonna use some
diplomatic cover and that's where roadie
comes in so we go to claw
and he kind of teases him shows him some
vibranium
and uh
shows some spear of the door melange
but rhodey's like yeah you know tony
stark switch as hell and he's kind of
negligent with his money he kind of uses
that all like in an afternoon 10 million
dollars no big deal so we see all the
vibranium that he had
we see the vibranium that he had from
age of ultron and this
this is kind of the same until it takes
a weird turn that i wasn't expecting
yeah yeah you want to walk us through
this one
well we find out killmonger is actually
a bad guy which i think a lot of people
were either guessing or weren't guessing
i didn't see them going in this
direction i was actually hoping to see
tony stark and pepper make their way
into wakanda and actually even maybe see
iron man go ahead and make the vibranium
suit right out of the get-go you know my
thought was well he's still iron man
talked about that before
yeah right it's like that'll be really
cool to see yeah and we did talk about
that before the episode today i was like
i can't wait to see that that'll be
really cool to see
uh oh my name's blinking her name's
blinking on me right now
t'challa's sister sure
shuri thank you shuri and iron man like
get to be together that's where we
thought it was going right right
obviously it didn't killmonger reveals
himself to be a bad guy
and i think claw actually puts it in the
perfect way when he says i'd hate to
play chess against you right because you
really do get an appreciation for
killmonger's intelligence yeah which is
very very very high and we don't really
get to see that in black panther
um not to this level like the game of
chess he's playing right and everybody
else is playing candyland like let me
tell you this is incredible so he shows
up and he just starts dropping fools
he's able to make it look like full
black condoms
right
black panther was killed by the
americans black panther makes his line
it was kind of
disappointed to see black panther
getting taken down that easily because
that was something isn't gonna happen
especially without him having the purple
heart seemed very unrealistic to me well
he did have like stark technology which
sound is different i think sound is
different you know
yeah
because like i don't know if you've ever
had like like i've had guns fired like
really close to my ears not wearing ear
protection because
stupid
and it can really
really
hurt
like
like inside your body like it can hurt
so
i guess if he wasn't expecting it and
you know it's good powerful start tech i
felt like it was a little cheap to make
the story work but again you make a good
point there well that's the only way
probably eric thought that he could
because he he's familiar enough with
vibranium to know that he just can't
like puncture t'challa right like rhodey
was shooting him and t'challa just
walked up to him and it's just bam
literally
vibrate like literally a suit made of
captain america shield it's a suit
that's a shield so how do you beat that
i guess that's one of the only ways you
could
and i guess that's another reflection on
killmonger's intelligence not just
exactly you know in combat which shows
up later in the episode and it's cool to
see but yeah so we get back to to iron
man and he's placing all these different
things and all of his games working out
perfectly or to tony stark i suppose
and uh it really was set up really cool
and and you know you don't want to root
for the guy who's killing all these
beloved characters but yeah i do have to
credit him like his intelligence
it is pretty cool to see him play this
this really cool game of chess against
everybody else for his own agenda yeah
it was really sad that we
had to see t'challa die right um
just because of everything obviously in
real life yeah that was rough i actually
thought to myself i'm surprised i'm
surprised i'm surprised they did that
i'm surprised i didn't change it at all
right but hey you know it's what if
different world it's what if and
eventually killmonger gets back to tony
uh
and you can never ever
ever underestimate the intelligence of
tony stark despite how arrogant he is
because he doesn't go through all those
experiences that kind of change him
right
in this one
so
despite however arrogant he is he's
still a genius and you can't you can't
really
put that past him so killmonger comes in
i brought you the souvenir and uh
you know
tony's basically you know
jarvis saw everything you can't get
anything past jarvis
and
he puts everything on lockdown
right all the like military-grade
bunkers come down
and killmonger's like what the heck do
you think you're going to beat me
he's like nah but the vibranium worked
as a power source so i made
a gundam right so essentially
almost the first iron man comes in
and fights killmonger now the problem is
the reason why it was so easy for
killmonger to defeat
the uh what's called gundam is because
tony stark says it you know it's
programmed after him
you know he says it right here
you forgot you programmed the drone
yourself your moves are his moves
i guess i got a freestyle that's kind of
where tony went wrong
why didn't you tell them that right hey
well there's tony's arrogance right
isn't curved by being iron man and
nearly dying and you really see
and that's cool because we see a tony
stark that we don't see in the mcu
because right from the get-go iron man
right from the ghost iron man and that
arrogance is
um served a little it's curved a little
like how you say that but it's also put
in check
to
contour
right so that's the thing like
throughout the mcu he's he has
constantly has to come in contact with
well i wasn't exactly right
exactly and that doesn't happen here
this is tony thinking he's right about
everything
and eventually just goes on to
killmonger defeats it and unfortunately
we have to watch uh
we have to watch our tony die which
again
was not expected and
i'm kind of confused here because it's
like did you just
i feel like that wouldn't kill you
and you it
it's probably about two minutes inside
of you you wouldn't lose that much blood
especially since it is inside of you
still
but maybe keeping it less graphic and
it's like to his heart but not really
yeah
but it wasn't
so close
opposite side yeah but eventually you
know pepper realizes what's the deal
it's killmonger but unfortunately
you know ross is there and like is ross
ever play
a beneficial role towards the good guys
ever
he is never right i've never seen like
black widow all this stuff you know so
he takes over stark industries you know
paycheck that and all of a sudden
kill monger because ross trusts him
because of the military background right
his navy seal
all of a sudden ross gets the army that
was his plan the entire time that was
his plan the entire time and ross gets
that er and killmonger gets that army
and
this is where his plan actually gets
really intricate
and this is where i kind of appreciate
it because again it's like dang
this guy planned all this and it
actually worked and so you have
he goes back to claw
this is technically you know the
military's army at this point in time
right now and ross even says you just
created you know the most advanced
military
whatever system against you know of the
21st century
so
this part is kind of crazy where
killmonger and claw they actually go to
the borders of wakanda
now eric is from wakanda right
and he knows a little bit what his dad
told him but when they get to like the
barricade the the barrier
he doesn't see anything and he's like i
don't get it and call actually knows
like there's a kind of a force field
that also
mass and makes the city invisible
killmonger doesn't actually know that so
there is some things that he doesn't
know which i found very interesting
so this is where he discovers it but
that's pretty much what he needed claw
for so you know after that
uh
kind of did some dying he killed claw
and i and this is like i actually didn't
like this part
really yeah because i was like okay
you're bad and you've killed a bunch of
good guys and he's like i'm just gonna
kill another bad guy too that i
legitimately helped him and i'm just
kind of like oh my gosh like
all right
i get it you're a douche
well he needed him he needed him so
that's the next thing i was going to say
he needed him to convince the door
milaje and to convince the people of
wakanda you know
that he's on their side and then he even
goes on to show him you know the marking
on his lips they tell him who he tells
them who he is
uh
prince of jabbu and
shows them the thing shows them the
marking so of course they have to
adhere it's kind of like you know this
kind of like in the first black panther
they have to adhere to that right you
know they have to ex because it's like
the royalty thing is like a big deal so
so it goes in and of course everybody's
still
you know what the heck this is
impossible
we know the story from black panther
where the father is the one
who actually killed him right
um
so the big thing with his father his
uncle killmonger's uncle
but it kind of goes a little bit
different
i think shuri's the only voice of reason
here
because i think the guilt
of
tichaka
is too much
um because of the death of his brother
and now his nephew killmonger is back
but that leads to
what we
actually haven't seen but i can guess
we're going to see the ultimate
destruction of
what [ __ ] maybe not the destruction of
wakanda but the destruction of
tachaka and t'challa's family
in charge of wakanda
because i definitely because you know he
becomes black panther at the end like
and now he's all powerful
and now he has access to a bunch of
vibranium and
i'm assuming in wakanda he could build
these armies again
oh for sure if he has all this he's now
black panther he has all their trust
you know if we were to get a part two we
would still see you know the breakout of
now general ross being general ross
versus
a fully armed and ready to go
hillmonger and
honestly wakanda's probably winning that
fight nine times out of ten oh for sure
for sure
but you know we had a pretty cool battle
this this whole scene here where they
were fighting the robots i actually
really enjoyed
um i thought it was really really cool
and again killmonger is smart he planned
this entire thing to where if they shut
the barrier
the basically what's happening is the
transmission from the drones to
ross to stark industries will be lost
because of how powerful the barrier is
but killmonger had a remote switch
it was able to reactivate them but the
communication back to the home base
is still cut off they just kind of came
back online right because ross didn't
see anything right ross didn't see
killmonger
fighting
the gundams
right so as far as ross is concerned
killmonger is still a good guy he just
didn't win the battle because remember
he couldn't see
now sure he questioned him the entire
time
yeah and at the end she kind of pops up
there before we get to that
killmonger jumps on the rhino which was
legitimately cool and this whole scene
right here this whole scene right here
again going back to killmonger's just
intelligence this is him showing the
people i'm with you i'm fighting with
you
you know not that they kind of had a
reason to think that the the army of
gundams was his but if they did that's
gone now because he helped destroy them
all
now we got some really cool scenes here
like really of okoye queen ramonda and
killmonger all fighting together like it
was pretty cool it was really really
cool to see
and i i'm hoping black panther 2 was
like
this in some way shape or form
and i wonder if they could bring
killmonger back in black panther 2 in
some
way that's not steaming form yeah in
some way that's not stupid
you know what i mean like oh we need a
black panther here's killmonger right
he's like oh yep come back turns out he
wasn't actually dead like maybe
oh yeah they kind of gave him a
heart-shaped herb
and it kind of kept him alive and he was
life or death for like a really long
time but you know after like a month he
finally came out of a coma and came back
i don't know something like that maybe
something like that now
he he eventually hits
he he kills the last
gundam
and he stabs it through the stark
industry logo
and that kind of is another just nod
towards
i hated you tony stark you were just my
means to an end and jabbing it through
the logo is the end right and there it
is right that's done that's the end now
we're in stark's dead
everything i needed for the means to the
end has now ended i'm done
and what happens after that
well he gets on the mountain and talks
to his uncle
and now he takes the heart-shaped herb
and becomes black panther and that is
the end of his plan right but
it seems like the way this ending is
here
where he goes and we see
t'challa again and we hear chadwick
again which was really really cool
because you know we only thought we were
going to see him in one episode and he's
been in what three now
this is the third time before i thought
he was only going to be in the in the
second episode and we've seen him right
three and i think there's another one no
i think he does show up he shows up
again yeah at the end
because because he's part of the
trailer where pepper is in wakanda right
we have
so is that the part two then we have
party thor then we have the last one
because we've seen pepper with um
yeah we have so they're sure so they are
gonna readdress this
they are gonna address this in this
season they've got to right they have to
because of the trailers that we've seen
i mean i guess there could be some other
thing that brings pep pepper to wakanda
but i feel like that'd be a repetitious
different storyline so perhaps we
actually do get a part two what if which
i suppose means t'challa probably won't
be in it unless he comes back as another
one of these panther ghosts well check
this out check this out i just had a
thought
what if
what if killmonger
decides to take jarvis and creates
ultron
and that could be a possibility because
remember the final the what we've seen
is a bunch of people fighting ultron
like droids
but we you're right we have seen pepper
and wakanda so what we have
yeah so what it what if killmonger
thinks he can do a better jarvis and he
makes the makes it out of vibranium and
he essentially creates ultron
and there's the
multiversal thread ultron with the
infinity stones can destroy the entire
throne in the middle of that somehow i
don't know if party thor comes into play
but i think that might be
i think kilmonger might create ultron
because we know ultron's going to come
right and he's going to have the means
to do it or it's set up right now that
it would make sense yeah and maybe the
party 4 episode is a way to get other
characters involved
as well yeah totally as you know we saw
in the mid credit trailer today
party thor and doctor strange but it
looked like you know the um
crazy powerful one
whose name is blinking supreme strange
supreme supreme yeah
i do think right yeah
so maybe that's gonna bring those two
into it and then it all meets up at the
end so there's a part two next week
maybe i'm making all this up next week
maybe theory party thor which introduces
other characters yeah yeah better word i
am theorizing because i do that for for
a living um subscribe um
and then we get the final episode which
will be everybody trying to take out
killmonger
and ultra and ultron
maybe i actually think ultra might kill
killmonger which would be lit
it would be lit i would very much be for
that
but that would be a cool way of kind of
i think it was
finalizing not a real word but why not
rising on words now too aren't you yeah
i'll do whatever i need to all words
um but that would be a cool way
you know some what if episodes at the
end because you know zombies isn't
coming back right right right the first
the second one's not gonna i do think as
coming back yeah i think we get as in
like these final three episodes here
assuming we only get nine and not ten i
do think they connect a little bit more
towards the end so that'd be cool to see
pepper and shuri together doing
something in wakanda trying to figure
out how to be killmonger killmonger off
making ultron right party for hanging
out with who knows who else bringing
them into the fold and then bam episode
nine well this definitely isn't done
right because
it seemed like yeah and you know what i
would actually really love to see when
t'challa when they're in the astral
plane at t'challa is like you know
either in
in your plane in the real world or in
this plane like you're gonna have to
face something at some point in some
time
so i'm hoping ultron actually kills him
and then like we're very good we see
this plane and t'challa does like kicks
his blood as a spirit or something like
that and all the other previous kings
and stuff like that too right like i i
hope we see that i hope we see that and
i hope they don't give killmonger like a
redemption in that next i think he's
gone too far now he's killed how many
people yeah but at the end they
definitely set up the next one
you know pepper
sure no sure he tells pepper everything
pepper never trusted killmonger sure he
never trusted killmonger now they're
gonna bond we know pepper's gonna go to
wakanda because we've seen that that
that shot in the trailer that we got
today and i think we've seen it before
too
um
and they left us on that cliffhanger but
it but now that we realize that
it does it's nice to know that they
probably aren't going to
they probably aren't going to leave us
on that cliffhanger for long
i sir i certainly hope that's the case
yeah yeah so what was this episode
called what if killmonger rescued tony
stark
well the next episode could be what if
yeah right what if
sure he kicked killmonger's butt
you know uh something like that so
i do think the next one
if not
the next one one of the future episodes
that we're about to get these last three
are going to be a continuation of this
but what do you guys think let us know
what you think in the comments do you
think
you know it's very clear that we get
this
this season
but what do you think the ultimate
ending is leading up to it does seem
like it's all kind of leading up to
stuff now
so what do y'all think it is
be sure to let us know below also if you
haven't subscribed to chris over at
cosmic culture be sure to do so
seriously this is fun we love doing
stuff live with you guys and being able
to chat and um make sure you subscribe
to warren if you haven't already
and oh yeah what i'm gonna hit you with
one wolf
oh no
oh no so i do the other wolf
yeah
and then the chat will do one more
the chat will give us one more
um no you guys are awesome
we're going to get to work
and we will see you guys a week from
tonight
for episode seven who knows what that's
gonna be but
hopefully it's a good one so
love you all see you next time woof